[Musique]
un combat de 39 jours le député jean
lassalle a mis fin aujourd'hui une grève
de la faim qu'il a entamée il y a trente
neuf jours il a obtenu le maintien de
l'activité industrielle dans 100 content
bernay il s'est dit apaisé lors d'une
conférence de presse cet après-midi
sandrine rigaud création de carnets
toujours très lentement mais il sait que
son calvaire se termine pendant plus
d'une heure à l'hôpital de garches jean
lassalle tient une conférence de presse
à l'heure où il parle il ne s'est
toujours pas alimentés mais ils gardent
le sens de l'humour en évoquant ce que
pourrait être son premier repas
steak frites
ou une
chine gars
de chine gare avec de la piperade chez
nous des pays basque du vial et
peut-être deux est au milieu je crois
que ça veut dire mais je crois que je
suis pas là il refuse de parler de
victoire mais au bout de trente neuf
jours de grève de la faim jean lassalle
a obtenu ce qu'il voulait il vient de
signer un accord avec total
jeu d'élus de trois fois quatre fois et
pour dire la vérité je croyais pas
je me disais je vais pas dire que je me
baisse parce que c'est c'est pas dans
mes habitudes je me paie jamais j'aime
pas me faire mal mais je l'aimé ce que
c'est possible après plusieurs jours de
négociations
l'accord a été conclu ce matin entre
nicolas sarkozy et les dirigeants
japonais de toya halle l'entreprise
s'engage à investir dans la
circonscription du député et exclu tout
projet de délocalisation
quelques heures plus tôt jean lassalle
avait été hospitalisé en urgence c'est
ici que françois bayrou est venu lui
rendre visite
c'est un homme tout seul face à des
puissances qui paraît si l'accès qui
parce qu'il est debout parce qu'il est
décidé à défendre ses compatriotes
jusqu'au bout réussir à
renverser la fatalité jean lassalle
avait commencé sa grève de la faim le 7
mars une initiative à peine prise au
sérieux à l'époque six semaines plus
tard jacques chirac lui-même prenait le
dossier en main une histoire apparemment
réglé mais qui refroidit les dirigeants
japonais ils ont déclaré ce soir que la
france n'était pas un pays propice aux
investissements
la menace est explicite
[Musique]